in season five of game of thrones tyrion
lannister and jorah mormont are attacked
by stone men in the ruins of valyria
stone men are people with a disease
called greyscale which makes the skin
gray and cracked and hard
and stiff and dead like stone eventually
causing madness then death
the disease develops slowly usually
starting on a finger or toe then
spreading across the skin
there are said to be three good cures
for greyscale ax
and sword and cleaver hacking off
afflicted parts sometimes stops the
spread of the disease but
not always greyscale is highly
contagious
just touching a stone man can spread the
sickness and this is what happens to
jorah in the show and john connington in
the books
george rr martin describes this as a
death sentence but a slow one
you can survive years with greyscale but
death is inevitable
there are other forms of greyscale
though one of which is often seen in
children who may actually survive the
disease but be left disfigured which is
what happens to shireen baratheon
surviving childhood greyscale is said to
protect you from getting it again
though in the books the wildling vowel
says that the grey death sleeps only to
wake again
which kind of implies that the disease
can come back
in any case greyscale is pretty rare in
westeros but it's apparently more common
in volantis and the cities of the roy
who send people with greyscale to the
ruins of valyria in the show
and to the sorrows in the books where
the stone men wander through the fog
until they die
some believe that the stone men of the
sorrows are ruled by someone called the
shrouded lord
who gives grey kisses and resides over a
stony court
one story says that this lord was once a
statue until a grey woman came out of
the fog
and kissed him with lips as cold as ice
which sounds kind of like the white
walkers and whites
might there be a connection between the
zombies of ice and the zombies of stone
for now we don't know what we do know is
that the stone men
are people with greyscale which shireen
had and jorah slash joncon now has
making him a dying man with nothing to
lose
thanks for watching there'll be more
theories and analyses ahead but let me
know if you'd like to see more of these
little explanations too